("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
(somber music)
- [Gary] One of the things
I've said a bunch publicly
is I haven't done mediation
'cause I'm scared it's
gonna screw up my brain.
But I'm always
willing to try new things.
Really excited about Inscape
Studio and app that I invested
in personally actually.
Along with Stephen Ross
personally and
we're excited about it.
Jacque's an
incredibly entrepreneur and
very passionate
about the space.
It's almost like if I started
a Jets business, you know?
When you get somebody who's
great at operating and is deeply
passionate about a space,
it's a good combo.
So it was good to
bring the team, try it out.
Think I'll be doing it more.
I got some practice.
Every time she was
refocus, I was like,
"Oh, my God."
I was in outer space.
So going from meditation
to getting on the stage
and getting crazy.
Good transition
for this morning.
Good day.
Lot going on.
Head to London tonight.
So should be good.
And that'll be that.
(camera shutter
opening and closing)
- Gary?
- [Gary] Yes, sir?
- [Rich] Oh, wow.
Nice to meet you.
I'm sorry, I won't keep you.
- [Gary] No worries.
- [Rich] Nice to meet you, wow.
- [Gary] What's your name?
- [Rich] I'm Rich.
I've been following
you online for years. Wow.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- So cool.
- [Gary] Thanks
for the kind words.
Pleasure.
(Gary laughs)
No worries.
- [Man] Can I get a
selfie with you real quick?
- [Gary] Of course.
- [Man] That's awesome.
I'm a huge fan.
I read your book.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- Listen to your interview on...
Lewis Howes.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And then I've just been
following all sorts of stuff.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- [Man] Great work.
- [Man 2] We've been
looking at ways to make agile,
iterative approaches
into predicting,
trending hashtags,
trending keywords.
- Cool.
- [Man 2] Before it even happens
so a quick example to make it
clear to everybody, if we know
Hurricane Matthew is coming in
two weeks, three weeks,
we're buying keywords.
- Yep, I get it.
- [Man 2] We
start selling duct tape and
glow sticks, water before--
- I get it, yep. Yep.
- [Man 2] How does that, are
you doing something like that?
- We're doing
that around culture.
So that's super
practical and smart and
I would call that transactional.
And I love that shit, I do it
for Wine Library quite a bit.
I'm much more
into that culturally.
It's understanding that
shadowboxing is happening.
meditation as a consumer trend
in the way that Soul Cycle and
health happened is a trend and
so we're making a lot of bets.
It's understanding that 14 of
Atlanta's hip hop artists are
about to become the
next Drakes and Lil Waynes.
We're doing it a little bit
more creatively and culturally.
It has more upside
and more downside.
The transaction stuff I
think is massively interesting.
The problem is for everybody in
this room, most of their clients
don't sell the entire funnel.
- [Man 2] Right.
- Right?
When you're a CPG brand, you're
not selling it direct consumer.
You're selling it through CVS
and that's why were at the mercy
of all these metrics.
The problem is the
metrics and the sales,
don't match up.
That has to be talked about.
I don't believe that this is a
call to arms to the industry.
I don't think we have all
these crooks or bad people.
I think we have an entire broken
ecosystem not just from the
marketing people but from
actually the brand side and the
clients and just the
whole kit and caboodle
is broken and the reason
I'm optimistic that it
will change and I didn't get to
say this on stage so to give
you something is as clients now
start caring more about Amazon
and Walmart's new efforts to go
e-com and direct to
consumer and as we know,
even the brands themselves
starting to sell
direct to consumer.
- Yeah.
- They're gonna start having a
much better read on if their
marketing is actually working.
Because I'm empathetic to
Johnson &amp; Johnson if they're
doing marketing, the reason they
rely on math is they don't have
all the data on what marketing
is actually making somebody go
by Band-Aids at Walgreens.
- I know. I know.
- But, Toby, I've not been in
this business for a long time.
I've been, I would see more
than 60% of the meetings I'm in,
the marketing math,
the CPM costs,
the impressions,
the you know things that,
right, look great and
then you get to the end of the
presentation and
the business is down.
- [Man 3] Hey man!
How are you?
- [Gary] Good to see you.
- [Man 3] Can we
do a quick picture?
- [Gary] Sure.
- [Man 3] Awesome,
really appreciate it.
- [Gary] Take care, man.
- [Man 3] Thanks.
- [Gary] Yeah, picture.
- [Man 4] Can I
take a picture with you?
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
DRock,
guys, it's this
documenting versus create thing.
It's so real. It is so real.
This has been an unbelievably
interesting year for me because,
morning guys, between
documenting versus create,
huge value.
The eBay challenge, huge value.
And now it's
going down in the DM,
I think we're
making real strides, DRock.
These are three phenomenal
pillars of non-motivation,
motivations always there, right?
But for people that really want
to get value in a different way,
a lot of the challenge
that I get from people is,
"Hey, okay like what
about practical advice?"
First of all,
I'm documenting it.
Just watch what I do, that's the
most practical fucking thing
I'm doing mother fucker.
Sorry, 'cause it's
just like...(laughs)
People want
little basics tactics.
I mean there's a ton
of free white papers,
don't buy the bullshit
e-books that will tell you,
where you going, DRock?
- [DRock] B4. (laughs)
- That will tell you
but honestly like just
teaching people
how to sell stuff.
You know teaching someone how to
fish versus giving them a fish
is always the game but this
documenting versus creating,
a lot of you is
starting to pick up on it
and it's winning for you.
People are
interested in people's lives.
interested in people's journeys.
People are
interested in people's crafts.
People are interested in
seeing different perspectives,
entertainment,
education, it's real.
No matter where
you are in the journey.
How are ya?
I wish, I fucking wish I was
doing this when the
early days of Wine Library.
Could you imagine?
(sighs)
(DRock laughs)
I can't even wait.
I don't want to be 50 but I want
to be 50 'cause I can't wait to
watch this stuff 10 years from
now and see how right I was.
Hey!
- [Woman] Hi.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Woman] Good morning.
How are you?
- [Gary] Good to see you.
- [Woman] Good to see you.
- [Gary] How've you been?
- Great, how are you?
- Good. Good.
How are you?
Such a pleasure.
The whole castle collapses.
Get the one wrong politician
who want to make an agenda.
I'm not even
going down that path.
Now, yeah now I assume that
that means what
it always means which
is you know Instagram
obviously has its policy,
like you know, influencers on
Instagram should be a piece of
cake because the policies are in
place there and accepted by your
company to do that.
- [Woman] Yep.
And I don't think you guys
are thinking animations, do you?
- No.
- [Woman] Animation is one
of those gray areas.
- No.
Meaning (censored) animation?
No. I mean to me like I wasn't
think about it yes or no but
if it's a no, there's
so much we could be doing.
- [Woman] I agree.
- Including like if we
really want him to come to life,
let's go pay for the costume and
have him run around the world.
Right?
What I want to,
I just know, I know
exactly what to do and the
only thing is
they're speaking to the,
you know, 19, 17, 22,
28-year-olds and I want to be
smart about who we
pick and how we do it.
This is such a
funny conversation.
It's funny because this is all
we ever do and it works but to
take and it's like the ambition
of my company to like get,
like this is unbelievable.
The level of importance this
project has for me is enormous
because I actually think
like (censored)
transcended our business.
Like we exploded the
growth of that brand.
It is the (censored) now and it
was all because we took money
from TV and put into influencers
on Instagram and Snapchat.
It just happened.
It just works so.
Can you win with one
when everybody else had eight?
You sure can if you
believe that seven was wasted.
- [Woman] Right.
- Yeah, you know?
Like that's, basically
that's the entire thesis of
the next 20 years of my life.
Why do I have the audacity to
think I'm gonna buy these things
and take them from
$20 million in sales to 100,
'cause that's what I done in
the businesses that I've run and
'cause I really think so much
money is being wasted because
I think the nuances of
interpretation like Dunk would
never consider this influence.
For him in the
way he looks at it,
this is like
mainstream. You know?
But for our
world over here, right?
This is so
influence compared, right?
And to me, mainstream,
like commercial
don't even exist to him.
It's like saying,
"Have you seen a dinosaur?"
- [Sean] More of
a psych background.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Sean] I went to
school for psychology.
- [Gary] Yes.
I think I'm the most
talented psych person on earth.
And I think it
comes from my soul.
- Right.
- And so I, I don't
want to become a data nerd.
- Right.
- I love the idea of
you feeding me things like,
the fact that you
just said that sentence,
we're set.
Feed me things that you
know I'll react to like,
"Hey, this study on
gratitude said these 4,
"7, 8, 9, 10 things."
- Right.
- And we'll just jam.
- Okay.
So things to bounce off of you
from a pure data perspective or
a mix of this is the big?
- [Gary] Give me it all.
- [Sean] Intense.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Watch something
I put out and be like,
"Hey, did you know..."
you know?
- [Sean] Right.
- [Gary] It's like a
did you know kind of thing.
- [Sean] Okay.
- Gary, meet Priscilla.
- Priscilla, how are you?
- [Priscilla] Hello.
- [Gary] Thank you so much
for the interest and hello.
- [Priscilla] And if you dig
into the details towards the
end, I break out, hey this is
what I was thinking
based on my--
- Yep. Yep.
- [Priscilla] six years
of brand experience--
- Yep.
- [Priscilla] of what I
think the split could be.
- Yep.
- [Priscilla] But,
as part of the pitch,
as part of the ask, is for
you guys to come back--
- Love it.
- [Priscilla] With
a recommendation.
- Awesome. I couldn't
ask for anything more.
Right, and then, and the truth
is that (censored) is the most
interesting because our belief
at Vayner and I think we're very
different than the market that a
lot of working media dollars in
the digital space are being
thrown in the garbage through a
lot of the things that people
are doing around programmatic or
banner or pre-rolls that could
be dramatically more maximized
in a social environment and
since part of this pitch is for
us to bring what we would do if,
I always think if I owned the
company what would we do, that's
all I can ask for and so then
that gives me the freedom
to give you our best at-bat.
I don't think it's too
crazy but it's all stuff that
I'm kind of into.
- Yeah?
- The Million Dollar Man
in wrestling's line of,
"Everybody's got a price,"
is still one of my favorite
all-time cultural.
- How often do you
have to do bad news?
- [Gary] A lot and I hate
it and I'm not good at it.
I know one of the reasons
historically this company's
gonna be better than
Wine Library was I wasn't
good at delivering vinegar.
- Yeah?
- [Gary] I was much
better at delivering honey.
What has happened is
I've gotten better at
it's been very monumental.
You have to be
able to be able at both.
But what I will say
is even when I would say,
"Hey, I don't like the way
you're not letting," I would
it's honey with vinegar, right?
It's like, hey,
I love you at a macro.
You gotta fix this
and tell me if I'm wrong,
here's my observation.
And then when you have a winner
they'll be like, you know,
they're pumped because
you gave them the honey,
they feel safe because they feel
if they're safe in a macro and
then the person, I'm
going back to this exact,
It's tough to
break up that pattern.
- Yeah.
- People got undermined in
the companies they worked with
before because the junior person
would go over and just blindly
fire the senior person.
I'm so 360.
We take forever to
make those decisions here.
(somber music)
- In a, this is
the jumping off point
for our next chapter together.
- [Randi] Okay.
Our next chapter--
- No more viral videos together
and trying to convince people
Facebook was important.
(Randi laughs)
I think they believe that now.
'Sup, man?
How are you?
Real pleasure.
How are things?
- Pretty good.
- Yeah, man.
- Very good, sit. Sit, sit.
If you're looking
backwards, it's over.
Who gives a fuck that (censored)
got nothing but
time and you've got it.
Every second that
you spend on being mad
about anything is wasted.
I'm mad about everything
and I spend no time on it.
You're gonna win, my man.
I'm telling you.
- Damn, that's fire.
- You know what I mean?
(group laughter)
Right?
- I swear to God.
- Listen, I've had a
little bit of time with you,
the thing you've got
nobody can take from you.
- Yes.
(somber music)
- Alright.
- I love it.
- Alright, so we'll
really, really break bread.
Let's do a late dinner and then
we'll go out or
something or like or like.
Off to London.
Gonna make some magic
happen across the pond.
24 hours of hustle.
UK style.
(somber music)
it seems like, yeah, you know?